we will next go to Samir from Metro
Detroit welcome to the program am I can
ask pronouncing that correctly
uh sammer sammer okay apologies what's
on your mind today Sam I know where it
is uh so I had a basic question so I
know you've been on uh Fox News before
would you ever go back on and debate
Tucker Carlson to sure his show I mean
here's the thing when people ask me
would you debate X Y or Z person it's
like yeah but about what you know what I
mean the thing about these debates is
and in particularly on the Tucker show
like I would do the Tucker thing just
for the publicity because it would be
great publicity but they set you up to
fail they give you an absurdly limited
amount of time in general and then limit
the amount of time that you're able to
speak you're given they can talk
overview because of over you because of
how the microphones are configured
you're set up with extremely narrow and
unfairly framed questions like it's very
difficult to show up and come off
looking like you really achieved
anything you know but for the publicity
and for the story I assure I would do it
but but the other question is about what
you know like for example
what should U.S policy be on Ukraine
Russia I'm not an expert in that issue
you know I follow the story and try to
be as informed as possible but it's it's
also about like what are we going to
talk about you know the Twitter files
might be a more interesting story you
know we we do much more media type
stories and the Twitter files is a big
media story where it was billed as this
bombshell and it flopped and so so would
I debate him sure but it would have to
be a topic that makes sense
yeah that that sounds about that's
pretty uh yeah it makes sense
um one other question uh so you I know
you drive a Tesla right now and you said
you're not gonna get another one when
you return your lease that's right what
are you looking at in uh as your next
vehicle uh I'm not really looking yet I
mean uh I'm gonna stick with electric
but I think it'll be based on what's
available at the time and depending on
when I get out of the lease you know if
an opportunity appears to get out of the
lease without having to pay 4 500 bucks
which is what I'd have to pay right now
um I would do it sooner but I know that
in 23 there's new vehicles coming with
longer ranges and so I'll just have to
evaluate what's available at the time
I I just know that lead times are pretty
uh I work in automotive and so I know
that yes it's really really difficult to
get a vehicle right now that is also
true if I wait if I wait they might say
well it's going to be nine months or
longer before we can even get you the
car so I I don't honestly I don't know
yet
okay well that's all thanks for uh
answering the questions all right Samer
thank you very very much for the call
we're gonna go next to JD right JP
Mandel JD from Little Rock you're on the
air
hey David can you hear me I can you're a
little low but I'll try to pump you up
I can speak up a little bit
um hey I just wanted to call in I work
for a power power utility in Little Rock
um and we just got some interesting
information regarding the North Carolina
uh substation sabotage okay
um we just got a bulletin from
the electricity information sharing and
Analysis Center
um apparently on December 3rd there were
three ballistic attacks at the North
Carolina and North Carolina that have
occurred at two substations
um the attacks were targeting specific
um aspects of the substation that would
lead these this authority to believe
that they were targeted
specifically to do that
um take these substations down
um the attacks were all with the same
kind of calibural weapons
and they stand out because they're uh
different than what some of the past
attacks we've seen apparently six
different substations have been attacked
this year in the United States
but they kind of indicate that those
were more seeming to be Lone Wolf and
this kind of General vandalism while
these attacks in North Carolina seem
more orchestrated
okay well we will we will look into it I
have not been following the story
closely but let me investigate all right
sure uh just uh just real quick uh the
it states that they
they have low confidence that the
motivations were motivated by a mix of
ideologies and extremist content
and the links that they provide provide
past articles about links to Neo-Nazi
terrorism and white supremacists
terrorist plots targeting power grids
okay all right JD thank you very much
for the call
no problem okay so there's an update a
very very important update